first this hour is going to be Moshe and
Florida hi Moshe how are you hi how you
doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up well my
life here with meteor first of all thank
you so much for taking our call
secondly we were we just want to mention
that we are also very thankful when we
were when we came to visit in August we
caught you in the hallway after the show
and you give us some marriage tips for
like six or seven minutes and it's been
great our marriage is going great you're
very much yeah
okay so our question is right now we are
in contract on a what we believe is a
good deal on a house two bedroom
townhouse and there's a about seven days
left of the inspection period and with
everything going on now and like hearing
today that that Trump has you know
banned the foreclosures and and
evictions until the end of April and
with the things that may have been with
the real estate market we are wondering
if it's a good idea to stick with this
deal now or get out of this and wait as
the values may drop for us to find
something better
yeah or renegotiate well the best
decisions are made if you pan back and
have a long-term perspective so I'm not
worried about from between on the end of
April on you whether or not you should
buy this house if you shouldn't have
bought this house between now and then
to April you shouldn't have bought the
house right I mean but I'm guessing
you're in good financial shape you've
done everything correctly you've got
your emergency fund you're out of debt
right yeah we got that all good and then
a good two strong down payment is your
employment stable below sometime is your
employment stable we have both nurses
working for a long-term care insurance
company so as far as we know it should
be pretty good for a while yeah okay
that's good news
are you both working for the same
company yep okay yeah same office okay
right now home office but in general
okay mother gotcha okay so the way you
answer the question is five years from
now which would have been the better
decision and would it have mattered much
I don't think it's gonna change I don't
think the real estate market is gonna
change enough that five years from now
that this would have been a horrible
decision okay I think five years from
now it's going to be a we look back and
remember the great toilet paper shortage
of the spring of 2020 you know I mean
it's a horrible thing we're going
through that's very real it's not as bad
as everybody's emotions have turned it
into but it's but it is you know it's
compounded in the self-fulfilling
prophecy into the economy now and so you
know that's making it very real when
people are losing their jobs and the
president's worried about people losing
their homes and so I'm not sure how you
get foreclosed on in one month in any
universe but I guess it sounds good
politically to guard against that
so because foreclosures don't occur
until you're behind a minimum of three
months in any state usually six to ten
months before a foreclosure actually
occurs and so if you get foreclosed on
in April you had problems before there
was a coronavirus and so I'm not sure
how this exactly helps but but maybe it
helps maybe it calms people down a
little bit and God knows we need that so
anyway if I'm in your shoes I'm closing
on the deal yeah if I'm in your shoes
I'm gonna buy this house now as agreed I
would not walk away from this house deal
because five years from now I don't
think it's going to matter one way or
the other okay you know we enter into it
before this whole you know there happen
yeah I know and the only way the only
way it's a horrible decision is if this
is if this is virtually the end of our
economy and I just don't believe that
okay so I think real estate in Florida
is going to continue to be an absolutely
incredible incredible investment what's
the next 30 days bring oh I don't know
let me idea not sure I got a guess or
two but they'd be just that there'd be
the same thing you got it's a guess so
hey thank you for joining us